this organization and every other  organization grossly underestimates the  value of organic content the reason  Beast me Logan others do well is 99 of  our content is entertainment or  education one percent of our content is  eat my chocolate eat my Beast Burger  drink my Prime Juice drink empathy wines  but this organization and every one of  its competitors and contemporaries  completely dismiss the value of organic  social content they over worry about  measuring its value if you're not  interested in making content that  actually brings value to the other  person not directly correlated to you  selling a six-pack how the hell do you  think you're going to build a community  you know many Community as a salesperson  has built  zero